thank you for joining in this is going
to be a second dedicated to exemplar
project so from this session today will
be transitioning from going over the
practical and the technical aspects of
data science related to biomedical data
and transitioning into discussion of
projects so we'll go over several
examples today we'll go over some
oncology examples you know next-gen
we'll go over some other type
microbiology project ampuls
and then we will talk about how to
structure and prepare for a project
collect the data and perform the
analysis well I'll give a little told
you of how you can start thinking how
projects especially if you're thinking
about oncology projects and this in this
session so we'll talk about networks of
cancer regulations yeah
cancer studies and studies that look at
different processes cancer that
underlies some of the clinical
challenges in cancer that exists today
and we'll talk about kind of the concept
of Precision's and modeling precision
medicine how do we actually think of
precision as some challenges in the
context of datasets that are publicly
available and combine those politically
available date sets datasets that are
maybe proprietary or come from resources
before we go into our discussion I want
to point everybody's attention into our
progress so let me go to the website so
as you know we track how everybody's
progress is going and we are looking at
two aspects of progress so we look at
the activity on the server how you work
on different pipelines and then they
also look activity that is related to
educational topics which is completing
the different successions or different
types of courses that online so you can
go to the organization page and see here
progress so if you click right here on
progress you'll be able to stand then
you can also modify the date range and
we started September 16th that was our
first second you can sessions down here
and today this is October 21st so you
can see how everybody's working on the
different practical things as well as
some online content that we have on the
world site I also want to point your
attention to all the participants so you
can system the participant in their
committee and I would want ask you you
can see that Sarah for example is very
active and has been throughout this
session
I just want to encourage everybody to
try and complete their profiles it would
be good for both our purposes for the
purposes of the program but also in the
context of this project part of the
program it's important because we would
encourage you to try and work together
with other participants of the program
you can potentially look at how you can
complement each other skills and
understanding of the different projects
so each project is typically comprised
of a number of team members as we will
see today especially in these Biggers
threes and we will see how typically
they include people that have a little
bit for understanding of the subject
matter in oncology a variety of
different aspects of cancer progression
and different aspects of treatment and
clinical information is going to be
important for those of you that do care
in the actual product some people are
going to be technique more advanced so
more able to assess the data analyze the
data integrate the day and then somebody
is going to be also more knowledgeable
or experienced with biological
interpretation so we'll talk a little
bit about all of these aspects but I
encourage all of you to just take a look
again and some of the participants with
the program so you can connect with them
and you can look at how immense they are
to kind of see who you might want to
reach out to now briefly I also want to
review kinda we have covered up until
now we looked at the program itself and
talked B FLE about in generation
sequencing and all mixed technologies
and we looked at how standard tools
could be used for processing and just
preparing the day for analysis
let me look at summary statistics and
statistical properties how you can kind
of visually and statistically fluorides
the data look at if data properties and
prepare some kind of overview what is it
that you are thinking of in terms of
comparing different types of data sets
or groups and things like that we
continue to explore how exploratory data
analysis can help us make sure that
we're not looking artifacts and make
sure that some downstream steps are
going to quell our data including our
Dom normalization log normal
distribution and things like that then
we start looking at some fistic ulm
essence that include understanding of
regression understanding of factors in
our analysis and trying to use
correlation regression to kind of
compare different things and gain
insights about features of our data in
the context of statistical significance
then we continue to learn about
visualization and work analysis where we
look at how we can look at interaction
between different ters and placing the
data in a VM we look at dimensionality
reduction how we can summarize the data
and kind of extract the most informative
aspects the data and we use that we used
principal component analysis to do that
and then we looked at data mining so of
unsupervised analysis like clustering
and looked at classification
discriminant analysis and classification
that really helped us understand how we
can select subtypes and understand
feature selection in the context of a
specific question today we're
to transition into projects to talk
about how all of these firm methods
could use in the context of a study so
in the context of the study we're going
to be looking at projects and his
project some of them already were
covered in previous sessions so I'm
going to just quickly review how these
different biological challenges can be
translated into a project so one of the
projects that we already looked at was
modeling precision treatment of breast
cancer using multiple types of salons
and therapeutic agents we looked at just
one Aspen that we looked at in
expression in the context of subtype of
breast cancer but if you look at the
full product you will set the second
component there which includes the
phenotypes that derived from testing hai
through passing of different therapeutic
agents using these subtypes of cell
lines so if you would like to continue
an explore project project is available
on the project page and let's look at
some of the other ones that you can
learn in the context of what we've
already covered in the program analysis
of the changing immune response in
cancer is a study that illustrates how
factor regression analysis can be
applied to in expression data in the
context of development context of series
where we looked at the impact of
different types of tumor associated
macrophages and their development over
time if you looked at the transcript
courses a couple of them used this
project called whole transcriptome
profiling of cancer tumors and mouse
patient-derived xenograft MA so this
dataset is interesting in the context
being able to study the micro
environment of a tumor we can look at
relations between being expression in
the micro environment and gene
expression in the tumor itself then
today we'll talk more about deregulation
of cellular networks in cancer patients
so this project is an example of how you
can collect data from multiple types of
studies multiple types of cancer and
integrate them together to understand
biologically what's going on what is
typical of cancer itself and kind of
separate from how it works in the
context of specific types of tissues and
also how the tissue aspect plays a role
in how cancer develops but we do have a
lot of other types of projects that are
either in the works are already
available so for any of these projects
you can feel free to reach out to it and
we'll guide you how to find the data if
it's not public lis available on the
site yet for example we have this
project for biologics production using
as part of Terrafugia para de and rhabdo
virus contamination an interesting
project in the context of biotechnology
and / - biologics our projects were
related to neurodegenerative diseases a
projects related to Ebola and viral
infectious diseases so we can look at
again use of machine learning and data
spend to kind of understand what got
wood drives spread of these the pandemic
or epidemic in fact diseases and of
course you are welcome to start thinking
about your own project but I do have to
mention that you know your project will
be something that you will have to
create with us and I'll guide through
the
the beginning steps of that in the
context of cancer will looking at these
four examples today so we already talked
to the modeling precision of breast
cancer in a bit of detail also there are
some other ones that we heard like early
detection of breast cancer biomarkers
and then some of the projects that are
already covered in the previous slide
now data science itself is not
necessarily focused as much on
processing the data so processing the
data includes pre-processing some of the
reads mapping them and then
quantification so we did cover that in
the first lecture but this is typically
related to the core informatics and not
necessarily really to themselves but the
two things that are related are the
exploratory data analysis where we
covered descriptive statistics
visualization and normalization and
analysis or how we can test hypotheses
how we can mine the data and using
different classification techniques but
there's an important other component
that we won't touch on so much in this
program but we do have other programs
that cover interpretation where we look
at annotation for example genes pathways
microphase these negative relationships
how we use gene ontology x' and pathway
analysis to interpret the biological
meaning of what we find during their
analysis steps so in the index of this
program will primarily focus on
exploratory data analysis and the
analysis itself the other two parts how
to prepare it and for this analysis and
how to interpret this in terms of
biology or clinical is really going to
be another set of sessions that we
typically covered in other programs for
example one of the things that we're
working on now is a specialization track
on oncology bioinformatics we already
had a program during the summer where we
covered the biological and clinical
effects of oncology and all the way to
interpretation of the found genes
pathways and mutations but we will in
this session cover a little bit of that
but not as detailed as the various
aspects of different types of data and
in different types of situations that
are covered in this specialization track
so before I go on I just want to make
sure that everybody has had a chance to
review the material we've had up until
now we have posted all of the vo
recordings of our previous sessions we
have some online materials that you can
go through and project datasets that are
already available on the site or
available for all the participants of
the program so we test that you can go
through some of those materials kind of
evaluate where you are in the context of
whole program and then once you kind of
do what is possible and what could be
done you of course I'm thinking about
your own independent if anybody has any
questions on what we've covered so far
in the program or what I've covered in
this part of the presentation please put
your question in the chat box and you
know all as well so ok are they into
sensations done earlier do we have a set
of recordings of them if interpretation
was covered in detail so I'll talk a
little bit about interpretation for on
call it projects
but the sessions for interpretation are
typically going to be around a specific
data type for example gene expression or
mutations or some epigenetic variation
all of those will have different sets of
interpretation methods and so they are
typically covered in our data specific
programs for example genomic comics
logics
onyx logic genomics is a program that we
just recently completed though there we
focused on interpretation of mutation
variants copy number variation things
like that and there we of course have
some of those recordings for that
session and we will be expanding the
genomics courses so you can learn about
that their interpretation of gene
expression is a part of the
transcriptomics series of courses
interpretation of epigenetics or genomic
data is also in the epigenomic core set
that we have so it's just looking at
those and then if you have any specific
questions you know we can talk about
that separately or we can guide you to
the right program that will cover that
okay
other questions feel free to add them to
the check so in the context of oncology
projects and a lot of the clinical types
of projects what we're trying to do
typically is find the underlying biology
of some clinically interpretable
phenotype so we have the disease
symptoms those are on the top on the
surface something that could be detected
fairly easily but becomes complicated as
you try to understand exactly what role
that biological process typically
associated with a clinical outcome plays
in a specific patient so we can look at
a challenge by looking at the underlying
subcellular by logic here we have type
of - good data that we can analyze for
example we can analyze genomic
proteomics transcriptomic epigenomic and
micro microbiome type data that we and
understand how it all works together to
produce a clinical phenotype and then it
also helps us to refine our clinical
data refine clinical phenotypes but also
helps us to understand how to go into
maybe earlier stages of addictive
analysis how it can help us identify
targets for treatment and how it can
help us understand the underlying
biology and study it so that we
understand how to intervene so again I
think we've covered some of this before
but a quick review in the context of for
example breast cancer what we see here
is a mammogram right and in the
mammogram there is this spot so this is
a clinical data set right this is a
clinical test a mammogram is
clinical test performed in the clinic
and one of the challenges is to say okay
when we spot this growth and we don't
know how to characterize it how can we
about this problem right so one way to
characterize this growth is by looking
at the tissue where it came from now in
an organ like the breast
there are me tissues that could give
rise to a growth to the tumor growth so
we can look at classification
classification really means that we are
trying to classify but a specific type a
name to the growth we can see that a lot
of this is driven by histology by how we
characterize the tissue where it came
from now a lot of times these growths
these tumors have some elements that are
non tissue specific when there are non
tissue specific we are looking at cell
types we're looking at how different
processes in cells differ from the
actual source tissue where they came
from this is called deregulation because
once a cell differentiates and becomes a
part of a specific tissue it's not
supposed to continue and differentiate
anymore so we expect it to behave in a
normal predictable way as all the tissue
cells behave but sometimes that don't
behave that way and so we can spot these
alternative types of processes by
looking at specific genes or proteins
and so for example we can look at
separation of different tissue into of
different tumors separation into classes
that are non tissue specific so for
example triple negative breast cancer
her2 which is an implant expression
of the herceptin or of the her2 protein
luminol etc these are going to be found
in a lot of other types of cancers but
we are trying to do this by detecting a
specific protein that could be you that
could be found using
immunohistochemistry where we take an
immune antibody and it binds to a
specific probe and if it binds we can
then say that it's present it's
overexpressed now unfortunately this man
even though it's widely used in the
clinic it's not very effective for
several reasons one reason is because we
just don't have so much tissue so
continuously staining the tissue
actually remove we use that tissue
anymore right so we lose a lot of tissue
so biopsy is a painful and invasive
method of testing so it's not used just
very often unless needed so it's
impossible to get all the information we
need just from looking at that the other
challenge is that we only have several
proteins we know for sure how they
impact the clinical diagnosis or how
they might impact our ability to treat a
patient so that's why the rise of gene
expression really gave rise to clinical
panels the that can help us in a much
greater detail understand a
classification again the problem of
classification in the context of
multiple players so here you can see how
Pam 50 which is a clinical panel help us
understand which subtypes of breast
cancer are present now you can see that
a lot of this is very similar but a
little bit different and so that's the
process that we're in the process of
refining the molecular subtypes of
answer based on tissue specific organ
specific right organ specific would be
breast cancer tissue specific would be
for example lobular or now we're talking
about molecular subtype for example
luminal or basal how are these tests or
how are these methods useful in the
context of our interaction with the
clinician so the first way that this is
useful is by looking at survival
prediction but we're really looking at
something that thinking man so here you
can see an example of the ten year
history of any different patients and
see how based on something that you
measure for example in year three we'll
give you a big clear prediction about
something that will happen in ten right
so that's the predictive concept here we
can take some measurement okay and so
will happen five six years from now now
the earlier we can go you can see right
here the separation is not very good and
because the separation is not very
addictive power is it going to be as
good so what we're trying to do is we're
trying to find genes in this example is
a panel of genes and you can see these
are actually from panels a Pam fifty
which is a panel of 50 genes out of
which only actually thirty-five are the
predict and the other ones for
housekeeping so they just help us
determine that we're asleep performing a
test on something that is a biologically
standard Oncotype DX in front panel this
example apply also to breast cancer so
you can see how this is a very important
aspect of our ability to measure gene
and predict clinical outcome what kind
of clinical outcome well we're looking
at survival of course which is our s
rate of survival but we're also looking
at rate of recurrence and rain
recurrence means the tumor will come
back now I always does it back as the
same tumor so here we are so have aspect
of treatment because a variety of the
treatments like key therapy Brady
radiology they can actually cause cancer
because they so cause mutations
because they also interfere with the
regular cellular machinery so the second
effect of the use of these panels is to
select treatment and so when we select
treatment we have the standard therapies
surgical therapy right so for example
one of the question might be how much
surgery is needed do you need to remove
the whole organ a large part of the
organ or just a localized surgery in
that sense it's important to stop the
growth and stop the metastasis of the
potential tumor and be able to get
everything that might be acting in this
you know cancerous way to remove all of
that tissue from the patient a lot of
times what is used is radiotherapy to
kind of stop the growth right so if you
apply radiotherapy you don't apply radio
to the whole patient you apply it to a
local a very specific region and there
you stop the growth stop the progression
of the cancer and then you can sometimes
even shrink the tumor and then you can
extract everything and hope that you got
everything right and but the danger of
course is that radiotherapy itself can
now cause any process to stop so that's
where understanding of the risk level is
going to be important for our ability to
select the
of standard treatment now chemotherapy
as you probably all know is dangerous
because it affects a lot of other cells
and not just the cells of that tumor so
another kind of paradigm shift in the
context of oncology is targeted therapy
right and what essentially is targeted
therapy therapy means that we can target
a specific group of cells and so you
look for example at how do we
differently just tumour from all the
other ones and select processes that are
relevant just to the tumor growth so
that can not affect any of the health
cuts now that's a big challenging thing
because of course cancer cell in normal
cells all grow and divide and so how do
you separate between them is a big
question but it's it really a question
of bonkers again right how can we look
at biomarkers of just the tumor and
found a treatment that will only target
that tumor uncontrolled proliferation
growth and signaling pathways that we
can stop that tumor from growing but
those same biomarkers actually work
together with the other things that we
before we can continuously monitor for
different molecular subtypes for rate of
recurrence and rate of survival we can
look at also individual patients because
they're not all safe so a good example
of this kind of a targeted therapy is
Herceptin perceptive is an antibody that
blocks receptor I heard two receptor and
oh this receptor actually is a gateway
for a signaling pathway and the
signaling pathway you can see the signal
actually causes the cell to proliferate
uncontrollably and so if we don't have
Herceptin we have this growth factor
that comes in and binds to the receptor
and the signaling pathway is activated
and this process of uncontrolled
differentiation happens in the cell but
if we block it then everything stops
growing specifically in the cells that
have an over fraction of this herb and
that's what you see how it made sense to
enter for her to over brush using
immunohistochemistry but unfortunately
everything is so simple for example with
Herceptin we know that there's a problem
of the change profiles of we use percept
in the off the time stops responding and
that's because the nature of the
cellular machine is quite complicated
and so we in continuum bombard you know
all these processes with the same thing
all the time and often times we need an
additional treatment to work together
with some of these tree targeted
treatment so we block the pathway and
then something else to block another
pathway and for example here what you
can see is are some of the processes
that are used at are blocked who kind of
effectively addressed this issue of
Herceptin drug distance what you can see
right here is acne how you can take
population studies and develop an
understanding of how this of profiling
correlates with these publicly available
data sets right so for example one of
the things we'll be talking today then
the contact of all of this clinical use
of some of these panels how do you take
a specific patient relation for example
let's say in India or in Italy like here
and you say okay well I had this
population is the population is this
population represented in these larger
studies that have given rise to these
kinds example panels or clinic
outcomes and a lot of times you can see
here is that it actually does not fully
Quilly which publicly available so it's
important that some of these data sets
they are comprehensive in a sense but a
lot of them have their own limitations
and a lot of these clinical studies are
going to continue to evolve based on our
understanding of biology of how this
works but also it's the exams that we
can look at so for example in different
places in different that patients
different types of page treatments and
with different combinations of
treatments right so that's why this is
probably going to be an ongoing type of
style that we'll see more and more split
up into diverse set of clinical
indicators to consider as we got the
data and what it tells us so the project
that we have covered up till now and
help us understand some of the biology
behind what we looked at now it so for
example PDX model project helps us
understand the relationship between the
tumor micro-environment
and the car itself and we can see a
complex relationship between them and so
if we understand that relationship we
get design treatments affect the tumor
and we can design treatments that have
the microenvironment a rapid tumor and
work together on them to suppress tumor
both and and that's further explain this
tumor associated macrophages process
where the macrophages which immune cells
that typically suppose humors but all
time the tumor can recruit them and
actually make them into tumor supportive
macrophages so understanding that
process gives us an idea of how we can
intervene specifically in those types of
cells that natural design
the minbari actually already opted to
fight these kinds of things right how
can we not only depress something
artificially but incur something natural
that already happens to suppress
something harmful and then here is
actually a way to utilize different
types of datasets that come from
patients but also that's from cell lines
animal models and how we can use our
understanding of type of experience that
cannot be conducted on humans but can be
conducted on cell lines and animal
models to really understand our ability
to intervene and how to intervene more
static and so for example when we did
this modeling precision treatment of
breast cancer study we can look at a
publication
we just by reading some of the words
mentioned in this kind of abstract we
can see how the types of things that we
have looked at in the context of this
program are actually going to be
relevant to these types of studies so
let's just take a quick look at what it
says first-generation molecular profiles
for human cancers have an enabled
identification features you can predict
their response however little known
about how these data types can best
combined yield optimal predictors
collective breast cancer cell lines
there are many aspects breast cancer
like for fast biology and measurements
of their ohmic biological therapeutic
responses a rule suited for development
strategies to provide the most primitive
molecular sets so hopefully this program
was effective to help you understand how
to interpret what they are talking about
we're talking about molecular profiles
so we just look at that now we looked at
identification of turns right feature
selection we looked at predictive
analysis of therapeutic response we
looked at the various data types that
exist
we looked at analyzing kind of the
optimal prediction right how do you
evaluate or predictive power of a test
and we look at you know different on
they can biological therapeutic
responses and molecular feature sets
right just going through this program
goal for us was to introduce you to some
of these things and you practically
because of how to use them so that you
can really understand what these types
of studies are trying to address so now
let's take a look at some of the methods
that they used and some of the data sets
that they had available to perform this
study so they used lee square support
vector machines
I believe we heard support vector
machines in the classification and
session but least squares is something
that we typically cover in the multi
helmets and integration random forests
of course we covered that and then of
course we use them to identify molecular
features which is feature selection but
from where so they had 70 breast cancer
cell lines and 90 experimental or
accrued therapeutic agents right so now
we can see combined onyx data with other
type of high through data and combine
them together why do you need to combine
them to that well what they found was
that transcriptional side which is
subtype based on just gene expression is
a very strong indeed contributed
strongly to response predictors for 25
percent of compound adding other
molecular datatypes improve prediction
for 65 percent so in other words that
sock compounds really work at the level
of gene expression and the gene
expression patterns could be very
predictive for about 1/4 of these
compounds but the other 3/4 you have
other month letter data types that are
strong predictors right so it's
important to understand that a lot of
data sets they have independent power to
contribute to the type of s that
trying to do and that's why you see that
null molecular data set consistently
outperformed others suggesting that
therapeutic response is mediated and
multiple levels in the genome response
predictors were developed and applied to
TCGA data and were found to be present
subsets of those patient samples right
and now after seeing kind of the
translational value of these types of
studies where you can understand
something really cool the features that
are in your data set but then you also
have to validate and then you have to
test your assumptions your prediction on
another Edison and so they refer to the
TCGA which is the Cancer Genome Atlas
data to validate the predictive power of
their test so today we're going with
that TCGA and try to understand how we
can liberate data set so that we can
study molecular features and their
clinical indication power and their
clinical application for all of you that
are starting to think about your project
these are the steps that you can think
about as we go through some of these
example so especially think of it
because you need to clearly and in a
focused way
frame the problem very important to
frame the problem very important to
think what is going to be this you know
this topic I'm going to put as the name
of my publication and when you frame the
problem are also starting to think in
terms of what type of data mining to
collect to understand answer the
question of my problem and highlights
right for example they were talking
about modeling provision treatment of
breast cancer right so treatment stands
out here right breast cancer stands out
and so we know that they want to collect
data from breast cancer patients
probably because though
I'm going to treat it so you need some
information treatment they need some
information about breast cancer now what
type of data from breast cancer their
focus was on evaluation of different
types of data that could be used as a
predictor for response and obviously
they need the treatment information for
that as well then you have to process
the data a lot of times we'll see how
the data comes in processed but it gives
you a variety of options processed in
from waste so when it's processed in
different ways it's up to you to decide
which one are you going to base your
analysis on so an understanding of the
processing is also important there you
can't just say oh okay well I'll just
pick randomly the first one right you
need to do this with some logic and with
understanding so hopefully you can
understand the different ways the data
processing is described so you can say
okay I'm going to use fpkm because
such-and-such
I'm going to use raw cow or I'm going to
use the raw single nucleotide variation
data in BC format or an other formula so
you need to understand what format they
are what are these formats mean what are
these abbreviations mean so that's why
we looked at processing of data for
analysis as well once you collect your
data many cases you're going to have
multiple types of studies that were done
in different labs that were done by
different people that were generated by
different instruments and to combine
that into a single data set that you can
actually explore and understand is
important and then once you explore and
understand a lot of times you have to
modify some of it or trust something
more than others because of your
understanding of where that data came
from once you've prepared the data you
will have to perform an in-depth
analysis and that's going to include
multiple steps where you probably do
some data mean you probably do some
classification you probably combine them
into a pipeline of doing multiple steps
and you will get repeated results that
you feel confident about
and once have that indent analysis
performed and you've interpreted the
video you understand the biological
meaning you found you have to then
effectively communicate the results of
your analysis and getting feedback from
people that are also looking at the same
problem so to help you start thinking
about this process we have this form
this is the form where you can submit
this information just briefly what are
we looking for so we're looking for a
problem statement right for example I
will take the breast cancer Cancer
Genome Atlas collection of samples and
analyze them for triple net breast
cancer patients and their age okay
something like that then you describe
your project okay why are you doing this
well negative breast cancer is the most
diverse set of patients that have
complicated field and really don't have
an effective treatment strategy so I
added to focus on the triple negative
breast cancer patients and I want to
investigate the role of aging in the
context of cancer which are obviously
related processes because of natural
accumulation of somatic mutations so
that could be my project summary then I
have to specify where is that raw data
so what kind of raw data did I used it I
used
prepared process they don't elect
threshing tables or did I take the raw
fast queue files and I need to kind of
explain that and probably provide some
links to reference publications why did
I decide that this is an interesting
topic focus on what are some
publications who is the principal
investigator again if you're working in
a team you might play a role but you
might be working together with somebody
else who maybe has a much deeper
understanding of the triple negative
breast cancer pathobiology and so you
might want to put that person as a
principal investigator experimental
design contact square or if you
generated the data or
generated the data for you you can fill
that out but if you don't just play not
na not available so that's is it
possible to get wrong fast you files
from this year it is but you have to get
special permission so you have to submit
your project for the TCA committee first
of all to consider because of the
private information the fast few files
contains raw data directly from them so
they require for you to have upper
infrastructure to analyze the data has
to be compliant with some of their
regulations and they have to approve
your project so yes it's possible but
it's not as easy as just going there and
finding fasting files ok so let's look
at the Cancer Genome Atlas TCGA and we
looked TCGA from several standpoints
the first one is the growing use of
machine learning and we'll see a couple
of examples the second one is in the
context of multi ons integration which
we all saw up until now but we'll see a
little bit more wide splittable analysis
of the kind of patient meditated so
first of all about machine learning
machine learning had been Boeing as a
popular method to analyze these kinds of
complicated and growing complexity
datasets so here's an example from one
of the publications this publication is
also in the Dropbox link that you
received for this section and when we
can see is that since the publishing of
the human genome project you know the
rise of the the publications that use
some kind of machine learning technique
right so it's important that a lot of
people are starting to turn to machine
learning to analyze this kind of high
throughput complicated data why well
because the
in this data are becoming more and more
complex and also you can see that from
about the same time there's also a
continuous development in terms of the
publication's and also the patents that
reference machine learning as well so
you can see that the use and then the
results are growing in importance before
example here is the publication again
this publication is in the Dropbox link
how people use machine learning analysis
of gene expression data reviews novel
diagnostic and prognostic biomarkers
identifies therapeutic targets for soft
tissue carcinomas right so again we see
the same pattern people use some method
of machine learning and you can see how
a lot of times this is not going to be
your standard approach it's not gonna be
you know for us out of the box it's not
going to be clustering on box people
have to think now to adapt these methods
to their understanding of the data and
the challenges that they presents you
know although the biological
significance of a variety of different
features that are used so you can see
that in a lot of these some array of
data is going to be used for example
here you can see that they use the
Cancer Genome Atlas and the French or
komen group right that has a genotype
tissue expression project so combining
two datasets together using again here
you can see three groups of tombs that
overlap and molecular profile is seen
with unsupervised T District in
stochastic named and bang his knee
construing and a deep neural network
right so now they've combined a number
of different scene learning methods and
then the three groups correspond to
subtype are morphologically flapping so
the morphology of tumors similar the
using a rain forest algorithm they
identified novel agnostic markers right
so they've all did exploratory data
analysis TV clustering right that was
their data mining or and they wanted to
find similarities of clusters by using
classification but it wasn't
classification based on their imitation
of clinical understanding of data
it was the interest interlinking of
different clusters right so you can
train masa fire on the results of your
clustering and then they used feature
selection random for it
to specifically met okay which are the
most important genes which are the most
important right we know its genes
they're looking at gene expression data
and what were they trying to find they
were trying to find prognostic genes
that are strong predictors of outcome
right so again now you can see that
their conclusion is that machine
learning algorithms are powerful new
tools to improve our understanding of
rare tumor entities right so he had a
very specific focus rare tumors they
used a number of different data sets
their own data set the French or coma
group and the TCGA is a reference they
applied some machine learning from the
data mined from the unsupervised
clustering and listing and then they
used feature selected to actually
understand what which genes are
responsible for this and they actually
try to do biological interpretation so
that they understand right you can see
reconstruction of regulatory networks
how is this actually working the biology
of this as well as how predictive is the
outcome clinical disease out okay so by
looking at these different examples we
can learn about how to frame our all
project so that we can make an impactful
study analysis that will lead to some
kind of exciting results another
like mentioned so the first one was
focused on machine learning the second
one is being at multi-platform analysis
of 12 cancer types right so this is
integration of data and this is actually
a publication directly from TCGA
where you can see that they are looking
at pan TCGA studies and will let a few
examples more the context of this
lecture because actually the TCGA data
repository provides us with all of the
pan-cancer publications that come out
based on the TCGA data so TCGA what is
it well CJ is a pan-cancer resource of
clinical and um extent and acts it
combines a lot of different information
you can find different types of cancer
so you see different tissue types it
also gives you information on different
means different patient's and all of
this data is searchable in different
forms so for example you can see here
the actual portal so we take let's take
this link right here and open it and you
can
see how in this portal you can actually
easily find data that you need but it's
to come in a very standardized protocol
that is difficult to man right so for
example if I'm interested in breast
cancer I can click here and start
exploring the different types of
projects the different primary site is
all breast right then I have two
projects of multiple disease types
genders vital status of dead or alive
things like that and so now I can see
how many you actually have I have three
thousand and six hundred and eighty two
cases so by looking at these cases I can
now refine my search and find all kinds
of phenotypic information then I can
study the data about right so I can now
also see the different types of data
that I have available for each one of
the patients a lot of patients to search
through for our purposes a lot of times
we don't know exactly what we're looking
for so we want to start the data mining
so how can we actually look at data
mining well you have here this is
actually an example of type of kind of
important features that have been
identified so a number of cases affected
and then these are copy number
variations specific information to gain
and loss in copy number variation right
dcn as you know is a gene I can look by
aim and see which type of cancer and
column number variation for this gene
where is it playing a role right so a
lot of different uses of this type of
study also NCI the National Cancer
Institute provides us with the data
itself and let's look at what kind of
data it gives us it also gives us a
catalogue of different other type of
gives us the true genome atlas for adult
patients and then also you have the
target point for theatric equivalent of
the DC GA it provides the radiologic and
pathology images so you can actually
look at images from the cancer imaging
archive and proteomic data so genomic
data is going to be all this sequencing
data that we talked about a lot in this
program gene expression genomic data so
DNA variation epigenetic data copy
number variation things like that
you have radiologic and pathology images
and you have proteomic data and also you
have additional data sets that are not
raw patient specific but there are more
conclusions so based on for example
somatic mutations in cancer somatic
mutations involved in treatment response
and involved in cancer progression
genomic encyclopédie DNA element for
example genes and isoforms would be gene
elements and then you have the cancer
cell line encyclopedia so encyclopedia
of different cell lines derived B from
patient that allows us to order a
specific type of a cell line to study a
specific or sub specific subtype of
cancer and things like that right as you
remember is in modeling precision
treatment of breast cancer we took a
bunch of different cell lines and we
need to know clinical information about
those cell lines
now the easiest way to look at the
different publications that come out
from the TCGA project is to look right
here they have and you can also click
right here in GDC apps and you can see
what they offer here data poured on
things like that and so one of the
things that you can see our publications
and you can search for publications in
in terms of dem types of cancer like
breast cancer relations it related
publications but also you can look at
publications for
pan-cancer sightings so that's what
looking at right now you can see how the
TCGA data became a resource for data
mining papers because it is processed
and generated and generated and
processed in a consistent way so you can
easily create datasets to study these
multi comic and pan cams types of
situations
yes specifically they even have a
category called pan cam Atlas
publications so pan-cancer Atlas
publications where they look at
different types of gene expression you
can see here for example supplemental
data right you can just see different
types of datasets that you can find for
these specific pan cancer studies right
all of Micro all of RNA expression all
DNA methylation it's an easy way to
brown your data though forced for our
purposes is going to be using another
portal and we can actually use an I'll
give an example how to find it so back
over here I have this link called fire
routes so fire browse is actually a
place where you can more easily download
the full data set that you're interested
in analyzing so for example you can look
at let's find breast cancer breast
invasive carcinoma bracha right and now
you can download all the clinical data
or all the RNA expression or the
mr.right so you can just download all
these datasets in bulk and that makes it
much more easy for studying these print
types of data analysis techniques that
we talked about in the context of this
program for example clustering or
classification so let's go
at one of the examples how we can
actually apply this type of a process a
specific type of a project so this is an
example this is a publication write in
cell will have publications that come
out from the Cancer Genome Atlas
consortium that actually analyzed
collections based on specific conditions
and then they publish all of the results
in one review paper so this is one of
those review papers called comprehend
and integrated genomic characterization
of hepatocellular carcinoma and it talks
about liver cancer and specifically a
subtype of liver cancer called
hepatocellular carcinoma which is from a
specific cell type hepatocytes and they
used again multiple types of omics data
DNA copy number analysis DNA methylation
RNA which is gene expression micro RNA
expression and proteomic expression also
and so you can see how they've
identified several mutated genes but
they also looked at other ways of
regulation hyper methylation for example
and finally they their goal would to
provide an integrative molecular
subtyping just like we did with the
breast cancer data incorporating
unprovided clustering of five data
platforms identified that I did sexual
right and they also developed potential
therapeutic targets so again we see the
same pattern multi effects integration
clustering identification of similar
clusters across small type of data and
then using classification this top gene
that could be used as potential
therapeutic targets and so you can see
kind of a visual summary of this data
right here and here we have the link to
the PDF of the publication which is also
available in the folder that was shared
with you so in the in the center of this
hepatocellular carcinoma they have to
give a reasoning of why I chose this
right
as you look at map you can see incidence
and mortality of HCC patients and
actually worldwide this is the fifth or
the sixth most new cases per year
worldwide right so eleven hundred and
eighty two thousand cases per year of
HCC so the pretty important area to
study you can see how its disputed in
different locations right and what we
have what is the type of we have to stir
this problem what we have is for example
from firehouse or actually from this
paper itself you can download the
clinical phenotypes for example you can
see the clinical few types here that
talked about ethnicity gender your first
race I her death etc and example if you
look in more detail from this paper you
can also see hepatitis serology BMI
obesity and other factors that they have
decided to be important to study
hepatocellular carcinoma so for example
if we look at the whole project overview
we can see that we have you know type we
have different tissues in this this one
just have HCC diff protector honours and
within each type of rama's have
difference so questions what can we do
with this data if you look at this data
here are three example projects one is
can we look at gene expression in the
context of pink cancer so they have
cancer tumors arising in different
issues for example rest and do they
share anything in common or how is the
issue factor playing importance in
development of these tumors in the
differentiation of these terms or
and 30 phenotypes you can a number of
temples and get the role a different
type of fee type place in the gene
expression for example the micro RNA
expression of different tumors and
another one of course that you try is a
can I try mouth comics integration can I
use partly squares combine two different
types of visits and identify how they
spray or can I take something like eye
cluster plus and how clustering would
work on multiple types of onling state
right so one of these exams is already
provided to you in draw a box which is
the six samples of pinch-to-zoom please
try and perform some analysis I'll show
you what that data looks like it's going
to be a number of samples that come from
different different it is downloaded
from fire around so you can do it
yourself or you can add this edit here
as an example so you can see that this
is Li HC so that's liver cancer habitat
hepatocellular carcinoma T P stands for
tumor so we have three LHC T P 1 2 3 3
non tumor which is not even from tumor
from normal tissue and then we have
bracha breast cancer 1 2 3 and not tumor
1 2 3 so we have six samples from each
tissue and the question is whether you
can find is there a difference between
tissue type burst or liver and is there
a difference between normal and tumor
okay so that's essentially the alignment
for you to try or helpful is that for
you to try and play around with right
and if you remember that
analyses that we've done up until now
you can think of a more of a mining is
there a difference and then you can have
to look for well there is a difference
in which types of genes which genes are
showing the difference
so take stated this is something that
you can practice any questions about
this so far
okay now that we are running short on
time so I'm going to try and can
finalize the patient but quickly but if
you do have any questions please feel
free to put them in the chat box on
behind to pause and address those as
well so oftentimes as you mentioned you
can also so three things right so the
first one is you can use different types
of aux data right no tonics intubation
second thing we talked about was machine
learning for specific type data for
example next question and the third
things really that in early cases were
looking at combining TCGA with other
resources or a lot of times it's using
TCGA as the reference another data site
database or they set as Newark for
example right so what are some examples
well here we have kind of building up on
same idea characterization of gene
expression profiles in HPV that's
hepatitis B virus related liver liver
fibrosis patients identification of itg
ba1 as a regulator in fibro genesis and
then here you have another example a
Pinkins or competing of genes regulated
by somatic genomic rearrangements across
more than 1,400 cases so in a lot of
cases you will see how data set for
example TCGA
does not have a lot of Representatives
outside of North America so if I went to
China for example which is what this is
from as a study of Chinese patients
could I study specifically HPV related
he put the cellular carcinoma then see
how is the different TCGA right oh those
are the types of examples that you can
leverage TCGA in and sometimes it's a
good resource and sometimes going to be
limited another way of course to do this
is here's a way to combine for example
mouse animal or animal studies with
human studies and a good resource for
that is the gencode product which is
identified classify on gene feed from
the human and mouse genomes with high
accuracy based on knowledge class and to
release the annotations right so a good
resource to study for example human
tumors context of animal models so these
are some of the pics that I want to
cover today specifically how can we
understand the clinical use of machine
learning for this type of biomedical
damn Onix
we can combine in different types of
arcs together to understand how they
relate to a clinical phenotype and what
is a clinically relevant phenotype
survival recurrence some kind of
predictive analysis or selection of
therapeutic targets and then finally how
to utilize find and utilize different
types of data set for example TCGA non
TCGA or combine them together for an
effective study and so with that I just
want to mention that in our next session
we're going to be looking at the same
type of project same type of a overview
of different types of projects but more
related to mic biology how can we look
at for example in the resistance
how can tuberculosis how can we get it
bolla is a viral infection that causes
disease and spreads as an epidemic how
can we use machine learning in the
context of those examples because we're
going to be talking about microbiology
projects I also want to encourage
everybody to take a look at our upcoming
metagenomics program so the meta
genomics program for those of you
interested in microbiome different types
of analysis of microbial communities
individual strains or DZ's clinical
manifestations of the
microbes like viruses micro bacterium
and things like that he will have
program that's going to start November
and we're happy to share the link I
don't know 30 min if you could share it
link for that program as well we'll be
discussing to find the data how to
process the data and then have build an
independent project using this data to
really understand mid genomics so that's
all I have today again team MEAP some
heat if you can add the link to the
metagenomics program how to register for
that that would be great and again I
want to remind all of you that we have
already we have pasted a lot of the
materials including this presentation
and the data sets and the publications
that I highlighted in this presentation
and you have links in chat so please
take a look at those as well and I'm
happy to answer any questions or taking
comments
Vamsi in framing the problem right so
frame the problem is very important
because you want to focus on something
that is novel and something that is
relevant to study your dataset right so
for you even start with the dataset and
you say oh I just want to do something
in Brest and you want to review some of
the publication's for example that we
talked about today or in general and
NCBI and look at what our high value in
questions that exist how can i frame
those problems in context of damn right
and then you go to selecting your data
so asking enough a question why do I
want to study this why is this an
important topic or others how what is
the clinical relevance of this what is
the pharmaceutical relevance of this you
know what is the epidemiologic relevance
of study so those are the questions you
want to ask or on the context of why
right why am I trying to do what I'm
trying to do now you've answered that
question you can have a compelling story
to study to breast cancer patients
because there is not in effect treatment
and there's a lot of adversity so they
obviously mean for better define
subtypes and new therapeutic targets
okay now you have your why that's why
you want to stop what you study then
you're gonna transition into how well
what kind of data do I need to be able
to address this question right and so I
think that it would be good for all of
us to review some publications exist in
the topic area that you have chosen find
that problem statement and compile in a
concise way to be your project title and
that would be framing the problem does
that make sense
okay what does the due date for the
projects so really is based on and you
want to have your project completed just
in terms of planning a timeline you know
it typically takes at least a month to
do something with your project depending
on how much time you have depending on
how much you already know how to do
right so from now we have some time
until the end of the program but it's
not that much time so if you want to
complete your analysis before into the
program I suggest that by you know
during this week is when you start
submitting your project here and we'll
probably take a times to refine that
project idea until you actually start
working on your project so I expect
everybody to have something already now
if you met the draft will talk about
these APIs and then my next week every
we can start their analysis and you'll
see how a lot of these steps that we
discussed today will play a role in how
long it takes to actually get to
something that you can feel is
presentable and effect
okay any other chase all right great
thank you everybody for joining today
and I hope to see you again soon
we'll actually see you again this week
and I will talk more about these my
biology projects thank